Wow we have a lot of people that are
holding and trying to get on what area
code should we go to I mean there's just
so many here to pick from let's go to I
don't know let's try the eight five
seven area code who's calling today from
eight five seven hey David how you doing
good who's this I'm Eddie from Boston
hey anywhere in Boston are you oh I'm
from Roxbury born and raised but I live
in Mattapan right now okay
very good what's on your mind all right
cool my quick question is with this
political climate right now what's up
with everybody voting against their own
interests as far as econ economically
their own interest versus what they feel
I guess I would label that as emotional
politics here's what is often missing so
I've talked about this a lot and
recently my thinking has evolved on it
go back to the Tea Party right the tea
party in 2010 right they all came out
and they're advocating policies of
cutting taxes for the rich and all sorts
of economic policies that statistically
will never benefit them they're not
going to be rich maybe right you know to
ten thousand well it doesn't make any
sense here's what we need to understand
to understand their motivation and
Jonathan Hite wrote about this like ten
years ago okay they are voting in the
best interests of what they perceive to
be their in-group so even though yes we
look at it they make 30 grand a year why
do they want to cut taxes for people
making over 500k a year doesn't make any
sense
that's one of my main things that
completely blows my mind
okay and what we have to our stand from
the left is they have identified it's
not so much a tribe but its group --is--
'no stew avoid the term tribalism their
group wants that so they are voting for
it because they perceive that it is good
for their group in total even if it's
unlikely to benefit them personally
that's that's what we have to understand
okay III you know yes I live in massive
Boston make I'll make a lot of money I
consider myself above average
class I am black on top of all that so
it's it's I sit back and I listen to my
co-workers speak about you know I'm like
okay I know you're not doing
economically to better or just better
than me so how do you guys this go out
and vote for these people that don't
care about your well-being and just kind
of this you know how like with a beehive
the the bee itself is not like the the
entity or the unit it's the hive and
what one bee does is not necessarily for
the benefit of the bee it's for the
benefit of the hive whether it's a
worker or their pollinating or a drone
or whatever what you have to understand
is that a lot of these political
preferences are based not necessarily on
what is actually good for the individual
it's what has been adopted as the sort
of orthodoxy of what is perceived as the
political group and that's why you get
people voting in ways that don't seem to
align with their position economically
you know coming from where we come from
david specifically in massachusetts you
know we have a melting pot of of
everybody everything and you know
viewing from the rest of the country and
what they go do on a daily basis of I'm
a I'm gonna say specifically the south
or the Midwest and the racism and money
equality and stuff like that and and you
would think with with general common
sense basis that people would honestly
do what's best for their interests and
I'm not saying that you have to be
elected leftist I'm not saying that you
have to be a liberal I'm not saying none
of that stuff but whatever benefits you
as a person in benefits your family and
whatever makes you make more money in
take care of your responsibilities
better as a man or as a person why would
you go against that yeah you got a
dynamic side explain it all right Eddie
great to talk to you appreciate the
phone call always great to hear from our
boston-based
viewers okay I'm out of topic mom I will
oak and he deserved that strange delay
sorry Eddie Eddie I think he was about
to say he had been following the show
for
I'm sure is a very flattering amount of
time okay I'm out of time that's it for
today we will take calls again